[Musique]
un nouvel animateur pierre bouteiller je
m'appelle pierre bouteiller et tous les
jours de 9h à 10h sur cette antenne nous
auront rendez vous ensemble je vous
parlerai à partir de ce studio 133 à la
maison de la rtf de quoi vous parlerai
ge et bien je vous parlerai de tout ce
qui fait le charme de la vie de tout ce
qui fait le charme de la vie quotidienne
une fois qu'on a fini son travail
quotidien
je vous parlerai par exemple des films
qui sortent ceux qui ont du succès ceux
qui en ont un tout petit peu moi je vous
parlerai des livres qu'on lit je vous
parlerai bien sûr des pièces de théâtre
de tout ce qu'il ya de nouveau dans le
domaine du spectacle donc mais aussi de
tout ce qui ressortit à la consommation
en général c'est à dire la nouvelle
voiture la nouvelle exposition la
nouvelle collection de couture avec bien
sûr un accent aussi sur les livres cela
dit il ne pourra pas être trop ennuyeux
il ne faut pas être bavard il faut
savoir s'arrêter à temps
aussi vous vous doutez bien qu'il y a un
programme de 10 dans cette émission et
grâce à jean pierre pineau qui
collaborent étroitement à cette émission
vous entendrez j'espère deux très bons
programmes de disques qui seront vous
séduire
bref dans cette émission il sera
question de tout tous les sujets seront
abordés
je me poserai partout et ne me reposerai
nulle part vous avez compris qu'il
s'agira bien sûr de parler de tout ce
qui a trait à la société de consommation
et en particulier de parler de ce
superflu qui nous est parfois si
nécessaire
[Musique]